heads up guys my name is China and
welcome to episode 7 of the Sparky gay
mansion series in which we make a game
engine from scratch in C++ so today
we're going to be exploring a better way
to draw things by creating a renderer so
first of all what is a renderer well
let's begin so a renderer is basically
something that is in charge of drawing
things to the screen so think of it this
way we want to be able to have data
right we have data in our game you know
stuff like I have a rectangle it's this
big it's located at X Y and it has a
width and height for example that would
be in that would be an example of having
some data right so we then want to
basically give the data to this thing
called renderer which will then somehow
based on the numbers we give it output
onto the screen something that visually
represents our data so essentially if
we're like I want a rectangle at 5050
which has a width and height of 50/50
then it would draw say a rectangle like
that on the screen maybe with a given
color as well for example right so that
is what a renderer is essentially we
provide it with data such as numbers and
it converts that into a visual kind of
form that we can see on the screen ok
so to create a renderer we probably need
to talk about how renderers work and how
awesome they are and also how how kind
of variable they are because we can do
we can do a lot of things mmm we we can
basically make this renderer in a lot of
different ways so let's begin with how
this is actually going to integrate into
Sparky so now you all know what a
renderer is we can begin so first up
first up we'll probably have a class
called renderer and a renderer will just
be a class that we have in our game that
has certain properties that correct that
every single renderer would have right
so this is almost like it's like a it's
like an interface ok it's kind of like
just a it's it's it's like an outline of
what a renderer should do so for example
a renderer will have like say a submit
method
which will be used to give it the dollar
that we talked about over here right
this thing will be submit and then we
should probably have something like
flush which will do this part okay which
will basically draw all of our stuff
onto the actual screen so these two
things are essentially methods that will
be in every single renderer on there not
something they're not something that
will kind of be in one implementation
but not the other they need to be in
every implementation of the renderer
okay that's why we're making this kind
of base class now how we handle submit
and how we handle flush so whether we
submit things by just adding them to
some kind of queue and then that's it
right or maybe we want to draw them
straightaway as soon as they're
submitted you know or maybe we want to
in flush we want to go through this
queue render everything or maybe if we
did it did it immediately we don't even
have to really do anything in flash
right there are all these different
implementations of renderers that will
actually handle these things so again as
I said one method or one implementation
might be to have this queue another
implementation might be to draw things
immediately there's a there's a vast
array of different ways we could
actually do this stuff so what we can do
instead is again have this kind of
superclass and then from then on we
could have something like say a simple
like a simple 2d renderer or let's just
say so that's kind of what we'll be
starting off with making right and what
this will do is pretty simple
it will will call submit it'll probably
add it to some kind of render queue and
then when we call flush it will go
through the render queue DQ all of the
queue items right so it'll get rid of
the queue of things to do once it
renders them and just render them one by
one all right it's gonna be that simple
at that that's a very simple
implementation of a renderer okay
another one might be like an immediate
kind of renderer which draws it as soon
as you hit submit thus it doesn't have
to store any kind of data about it or
anything like that that could be another
implementation and then as we go on of
course we'll have to think of a more
efficient way to render things because
right now what I've described as a
simple 2d renderer what I will do is it
will simply take things
equate them to what I call what what are
basically called draw calls okay and
we'll talk a bit we'll talk more about
this in a minute but the first thing I
want to cover is this submit thing right
what does it take
like what's when we submit something we
need to specify what we're submitting
right so what kind of data what format
is this submission data going to be in
well we also have to have something
called a renderable so a renderable is
basically an object which the renderer
will render okay so an example of a
render rule might be something like a
sprite okay in fact we'll probably have
render a 2d and then renderable 2d all
right we'll have stuff like that
but a sprite is an example of a
renderable 2d yeah a renderable 3d will
probably have something like a position
so you XY right so we'll have a position
it might have a size and it might have a
color and it might have like a tax ID or
you know a bunch of texture coordinates
whatever right it might it'll have all
of that stuff that we need to actually
draw this 2d thing onto the screen so
the position might be like avec 3
probably even though it's 2d right so in
this case the Z value since it is 2d and
it doesn't take that we have a Zed the
Zedd will just control the render order
so whether or not something will be in
front or behind 1 right so if this has
like a set of 2 and this has a set of
one it will prefer it'll render this one
first and then that one right I meant
the other way around but the point is we
can just give opengl Zed numbers even
for kind of things and orthographic
projections obviously and it will still
it'll basically use that as the depth
buffer and figure out what things are in
front of what other things right so
pretty cool but anyway will happen so
like that size will probably be a vector
color might be avec for you know we've
got all these different attributes that
we give to our Ren durables so that when
we actually submit a renderable to this
and it adds it to say the queue when we
call flush it will go through the queue
and it will take all this data and all
convert it into some kind of OpenGL
buffer and submitted and render it and
everything will be just the best so that
is the basic overview now let's talk
about
some more technical things that we need
to accomplish this first of all if we
are doing doing it this way where
basically we submit a renderable let's
just I'm gonna call render balls from
now on I'm just gonna call them sprites
okay you know game will still have a
render a little 2d as an actual
superclass off sprite but I'm just gonna
call them sprites in this demonstration
so when we submit say a sprite and then
it renders it we need to basically
construct a buffer with all of this data
so that OpenGL can render it okay
furthermore when we submit things to BQ
and when we flush them what will
basically happen is the flush will
literally just be a for like for all of
our cube stuff it'll simply be a like a
full loop with all about cue stuff and
then what it will do is it'll what am i
doing what it will do is it'll go
through all of this stuff and construct
some kind of buffer out of it okay or at
least that's what it does right now and
basically it will there'll be a draw
pool in here so we might do something
like geo draw arrays or draw elements or
something like that yeah which is a draw
all right so we have something like that
in this for loop so what happens then is
because this will happen for each of the
sprites in our queue is the system we
have set up right now is that one sprite
equals one draw call right that is the
ratio it's a one-to-one ratio between
surprise and draw calls that is not the
best idea when you have a lot of sprites
you want to draw okay
our target I mentioned in like the first
episode in the planning one was we want
to hit fifty thousand sprites on the
screen at once right if we have one draw
call pass bright there's no way that's
gonna happen okay so we actually want to
probably be a bit smarter about how we
do this and pack them in into one buffer
and then just have like one draw call or
maybe couple draw calls or something
like that yep but the idea is we don't
want to have a one-to-one draw call
eventually but we'll do this we'll do it
this way first because it's much simpler
and I'll get something on the screen and
it's probably nice to have this kind of
renderer anyway right and then
eventually we'll have a different
implementation of render a 2d what
we'll actually basically pack all of
these sprites into one buffer and then
render them or something like that right
so we'll have multiple implementations
as what I'm saying but anyway for this
simple 2d renderer to work we definitely
do not want to be constructing buffers
every single frame okay that's not good
that's going to be even slower than
one-to-one draw calls right we don't
want to be doing that so what we do want
to do is we kind of want these
renderable 3ds or at least this sprite
right we might even call it simple
sprite or something like that and what a
simple sprite will have or what this
renderable 3d will have is essentially
it should have already built up a vertex
buffer which has all of our vertices in
it which are going to be calculated from
the positions and the size it should
have an index buffer which is probably
going to be the same for every sprite so
we might make that static or something
right but these are all the indices that
will render and I'll explain these two
things in a minute and then it might
have like a buffer full of colors we
might have a color buffer right we might
have a bunch of stuff well probably not
gonna focus too much on that stuff today
but we'll have you know texture buffers
whatever we'll have a bunch of buffers
but what I'm saying is instead of
calculating and creating these vertex
buffers like creating a new one every
frame here which will be very slow what
we can do instead is when we actually
create a new sprite we can go ahead and
say let's let's add at the actual
construction of the sprite let's create
these objects based on how we make the
sprite so for example its position and
its size so all that stuff so for
example if we're creating a sprite that
we want to have at 8 comma 10 X&Y with a
size of 5 5 right so it's just a square
for example we probably want to do
something like create a buffer full of
vertices based on the size right not
this so we'll have something like this
vertex buffer will just be a buffer of
it'll be an array of GL floats okay
which will basically just be you know
something like 0 0 maybe 0
five five limps five five five zero I
don't know I'm just making stuff up
right it'll be something like that which
has the width height we probably want to
set up some kind of model matrix okay so
we'll have a model matrix that the model
matrix right which will basically have
an x and y it'll be it'll be a
translation matrix which has a vector e
of 8 10 and I don't know 0 for 0
whatever we might dictate the order well
we might take in as ad for this right or
something like that yeah and then what
we do is when we want to draw this
instead of creating the buffer we take
the already existing buffer and use it
to draw our element so we bind it and
probably will definitely show this all
into a vertex array by the way but will
will bind all that stuff and we'll draw
it okay and that's it so that's that's
our whole kind of workflow so hopefully
all you guys understand that it was
pretty brief but we do have to start
implementing this stuff but yeah that's
it that's kind of the idea okay
so that'll be a bit faster than actually
recreating that buffer okay we created
one we create sprite because it's not
gonna change right the size of the
sprite is not going to change at least
we're not gonna let it and it in fact if
we do decide to change the sprite maybe
like that would be a good good time to
actually recreate the buffer okay so
again we can support resizable sprites
obviously or maybe they'll change shape
as well they'll go from like a a square
to a rectangle that's totally okay it's
just that we'll make it at set size or
whatever it will actually read it buffer
but we definitely don't need to do every
frame okay that's the idea let's get
cracking so what we need right now one
thing I want to mention quickly is that
all of these lovely buffers right they
obviously should be belonging to the
same renderable 2d so when we decide to
draw them we need to somehow say these
are all of our buffers draw it using
those buffers so basically we need to
bind all of them so instead of so that's
kind of impossible to do so what we need
to do instead
basically how's all of these buffers in
a vertex array okay and a vertex array
is a vertex array is basically just a
bunch of buffers in one array right so
what happens eventually is that all this
buffer data that we have so this is an
example so there's a vertex array for
example of it's it's very this vertex
buffer will basically just contain this
stuff right and a buffer is basically
just an array yes a buffer is kind of
defined as a temporary like a temporary
location to store stuff right a
temporary memory location but really
just think of it as an array right
because that's basically what it is we
write it the buffer in the moon then
that buffers get sent to the graphics
card so what happens is all of our
vertices such as the such as all this
stuff gets sent to our shaders all right
and then our shaders will have inputs
for say the position the color the
texture coordinates whatever it has all
these things it's sent it's sent to them
via attributes essentially so shader
attributes pieces of data that gets sent
in per vertex so per this thing so each
of these would be an example of an
attribute because it gets it gets sent
in from the CPU to the GPU per vertex
whereas something you probably would
have heard called a uniform happens
heard like actual drop all so it doesn't
happen per vertex that happens per
primitive essentially we can't set them
in between vertices whereas we can for
attributes and that's kind of important
because we want to the vertex shader for
example happens for each vertex so we
kind of need to transmit each vertex
separately but the idea is that these
shaders accept all this data and then
they will output a color based on these
like locations for example
all right so bet if I fund like on a
triangle between these three points then
the treatment trader will then construct
or the fragment shader once that
rasterizes everything will just
basically set this color to whatever we
specify it to do so the idea is we give
our shaders this information and
whatever we do in the shaders they
what actually gets done with this
information but all these things are
just ways to basically call the shaders
okay so that is a huge workflow of how
all of this is going to work let's jump
in and actually make it work now so the
first thing we're going to do is under
graphics I'm going to make a new folder
called buffers okay so this is what's
going this is basically what's going to
contain all of our different kinds of
buffers that we've kind of done okay
so first I'm going to create a vertex
buffer so I think one thing that I
really want to mention is that a vertex
buffer I say as I type array a vertex
buffer does not actually have to have
vertices I'm just calling it a vertex
buffer because I only want to call it a
buffer but it you know what I want to go
ahead and probably call it a buffer
because really that would probably be
the best way to go about things
so buffer is the new name of this so it
will also make a super big file buffers
are commonly used with vertices like
well I say commonly because you kind of
you can't really have colors without
vertices but you have vertices Matar
colors right so usually a vertex buffer
is the minimum requirement to actually
draw something on the screen so anyway
let's pragma once this so this buffer is
going to basically contain all the stuff
we need to actually convert an input
array just a normal array into an OpenGL
buffer okay that's all it does so let's
make sure that we put it into our
glorious namespace I said it'll still be
in the graphics right because it's an
OpenGL offer
and then I think we can probably just go
ahead and let's say so we'll need OpenGL
for this so we'll probably just include
GL and then glue okay so this buffer
will have it'll have a let's see so
we'll have a an unsigned int called M
buffer ID so this is going to be the
actual ID that OpenGL provides us when
we create the buffer and then I think
we'll also probably have something
called the component count so that when
we actually set up our shaders and we we
set up our vertex array to actually
transmit these buffers to the shaders
it's a good idea to know how many
components are in this buffer what I
mean by that is basically whether we
have vector ease or vectors or Veck
force so since this will be just an
array of floats such as 2.0 f1o 2.0 F
3.0 a lot right if these were positions
we need to tell it say these are two
components coordinates so in other words
this is one this is one vector this is
one vector because it could also be one
vector for right
so we want to somehow we basically want
to have a component count so that we can
tell the vertex actually be a pointer to
basically how this data should be
interpreted okay so when we set this up
we want to have a vertex buffer which
takes in our data just as a GL float
okay we'll have a count
we obviously need to have a count for
how basically what is in this array how
many elements are in that all right um
yeah that's it so then we'll just have
the component counter I think that's
probably it
okay we should also have avoid enable
and avoid disable okay and then this
will just I'll just call it blind and
online I think so this will bind and
unbind the array and I've called it
vertex
this will bind and unbind the buffer
okay cool so anyway that's how basic
class set up let's copy these into here
and and we will implement all this stuff
so let's just copy this stuff okay so
we'll go ahead and we'll set okay so the
data were actually gonna do something
with the data so we want me to copy that
let's make sure we have out thing out
front yeah umm yeah so daughter will
actually be passed in but stuff like
counts really the only thing we need to
do well the only feel when you say is a
math opponent count we'll set that equal
to component count all right cool so GL
gen and buffers is the beginning of this
so we want to generate one bar huh and
we want to basically set its ID to ember
Friday right we then want through binds
the buffer so it'll be a gel array
buffer okay so yeah alright so GL array
buffer just means that it is essentially
this buffer is literally just an array
of data okay and then we'll go ahead and
actually specify what our data is for
the buffer so gel right buffer next we
need to specify the size of leaves so
that'll be counted times so it's a
silent bytes by the way not in actual
like floats for example so if it is if
our data is floats which they are we
should multiply the count by the size of
each float because that'll give us the
size in bytes next up we have the actual
data okay so we can just get the data
and then finally we have the usage so
for now we'll just use GL static drop
because we don't intend to actually
change the data or anything like that so
there we go
so now as done let's unbind it so if we
bind a buffer 0 obviously that will just
unbind everything let's go ahead and
implement
vines and whatnot so vines will of
course simply do this and then unbind
will do the exact same thing but with
zero and then we need a way to get the
component count as well so I'm buying
2-0 I think I might just this looks a
bit weird so I think I might just move
this thing into the initializer it
doesn't really make a difference but I
thought it might just look might might
make the code look a bit nicer because
this is just all of our OpenGL binding
stuff anyway now that we roll this lets
probably make some kind of GL you ain't
getting turn into counts pumps which
holds just yeah we'll just return it
we'll just return an account we can on
that as well all right cool there we go
so that's our master plan I'll probably
just leave that down there that's our
master plan for buffers so as you can
see it's very simple okay all we do is
we give it a bunch of data and it
generates an open job offer out of it
that that's it that's really the extent
to which this buffers thing will go so
the next thing we need to do is actually
make an index pop-up so let's talk about
indices quickly as well I'll just make
an index buffer dot H and an index
buffer dot CPP all right cool so what is
an index buffer and water indices so
when we have vertices that we want to
draw right the way that we typically
draw things is by using triangles right
so if I want to draw a like a square or
a rectangle I basically draw it by
drawing two triangles now as you can
probably notice in every square if we
draw it in terms of triangles there are
two redundant points
of data okay two vertices that are
redundant they're over here because if
I'm drawing say this one over here then
I need these three vertices and then if
I'm drawing this one over here
I also need three vertices and if it's a
square again these two will actually be
the same and then we'll have one more
unique one so really there are there
should only be four vertices because
these two are basically duplicates so
the question is how can we only have
four vertices if we need to draw six
vertices well that's where indices come
in so basically let's just say this data
was something like maybe this was 0 5
this was 5 sorry this was 0 0 this was 5
0 and then this was 5 5 right so this is
just an example of what the cordons
actually are instead of having 0 0 & 5 5
written twice we can actually just have
a bunch of indices so indices are
basically I guess indices are just they
basically it's almost like a like a
lookup table it tells you which vertices
to read so if we have if we have this
and we want to use these four vertices
to draw this well how do we do it if we
start say over here for example we might
want to basically grab index 0 so if I
label these as 0 1 2 & 3 I should
probably use a different color for that
though so 0 1 2 3 right yeah so if I
want to basically draw this I might want
to take index 0 then I probably want to
take it number 1 and then I might want
to take two so that'll draw that up too
that's using 0 1 & 2 which will draw
this triangle right and then I have to
draw the other triangle so I can
probably just do I want to take the same
point so I could probably just go to 3 0
right 2 3 0 so 2 3 & 0 and look that's
another triangle ok so basically by
having this list of numbers which tell
me which vertex to read so that I can
draw this triangle or these two
triangles great this square
by having this I'm avoiding having six
vertices like I only need four okay in
this case as you can imagine once you
have will say 3d models which use even
more kind of redundant stuff and you
might have stuff like that you can see
that all of these points right this at
this point has like at the moment three
of the same like three vertices that are
the exact same right this one has like
towards one has to this one s two you
can see it gets it starts to add off and
it's basically a lot easier to have
indices okay
so that so that's basically what indices
are yeah they just let us kind of
specify which vertex from our list two
vertices we want to use to draw a
selected triangle so that being said
let's basically copy everything that we
had here and here because it's going to
be very much similar so in here I'll
just adjust our namespaces make them all
pretty okay and I'll call this an index
buffer okay because that's what it is
and we don't need a component count okay
we'll still need a buffer ID what we do
need though actually instead of a
component count is just a count okay
because we need to know how many indices
there are since we need to pass that
into our draw wall so that it can
actually draw it so able to well any
minute as well so get counts which will
just return count bind unbind everything
will be the same instead of jail float
so we'll check we'll take in jail
unsigned shorts
okay unsigned byte is probably good
other thing an unsigned int is also okay
make sure it's unsigned we'll get onto
that in a minute but um the idea is that
a short or an unsigned short is capable
of basically storing up to around like
65536 different values okay so from 0
all the way to 6 5 5 3 6 which is 2 to
the power of 16 right because it's 16
bits so basically it is shortly an
unsigned short or a normal short takes
up 2 bytes of data okay whereas an
integer will take up 4 bytes of data
which
double the memory usage right so our
question is is this going to be enough
indices and my answer is yes because
where's comes to worst that we have two
options if we need more than 65,000
indices which potentially is probably
going to happen actually to be honest
but if we need that many indices we can
either switch to an int right or we can
split up the draw wall so we can then
just say let's split this up into a
different drawer call and draw these
indices again but using a different
bunch of vertex data for example right
so we can change it into an unsigned int
which would give us about four billion
ish indices but this is gonna be tough
now so let's just do that so back here
we've got our shorts okay okay the other
option is obviously using vice so if we
had an unsigned byte yeah that gives us
from 0 to 255 and I should have probably
said that this is actually 2 divided by
3/5 because 6 for 536 is in total amount
of values right so we obviously since
we're something is your not one we have
to fight we go all the way up to 6.5 35
okay but 2 to the power 16 is 65536
anyway the point is that we only have
255 that's kind of low I'd say that's
probably going to wear but we'd like to
get out of it again drawing one sprite
we need exactly up to three okay we need
for different values we just need up to
three that's the maximum number we have
to support to have that so really could
be like two bits okay that's really all
we need to draw one sprite to the screen
okay so it's it's gonna get more
complicated when we start packing
sprites and when we start actually using
3d models and all that stuff which we
will get to eventually but the idea is
for now this should be enough that's
slightly too small that's probably the
right size and 4 billion is slightly too
large so we're going to stick with this
anyway that was quite an in quite an
in-depth explanation but let's move on
and
create this so the different the key
difference here right and there's not
there's really no real big difference
but the key difference here is that
instead of binding to a GL array buffer
we're going to bind to a gel element
array buffer okay and similarly we're
going to draw our draw calls are going
to be using GL draw elements which is
basically similar to GL draw arrays
except it uses indices which is what we
want so let's change all of this to be
element array buffer everything else
will stay the same obviously make sure
you're using GL you short instead of
float here because that will literally
be half a size of a float everything
else looks good
make sure you change this up instead of
component count yeah make sure you
include index buffer that's probably
important yeah everything else looks
pretty good so instead of am promoting
count of course we just want count and
we don't need this anymore so back here
we can just delete that and I think
everything else looks pretty good so
we've got one side shorts good and we've
got the last time yeah everything looks
pretty good yeah I'm pretty satisfied
with that okay so that's done now we
need to basically pop our stuff into an
array so we need to talk about we need
to talk about vertex arrays in a minute
so let's create a vertex array dot H
this is kind of the final step
multiple go everything working so an
array a vertex array as I said it's just
a basically it's almost like a bunch of
vertex data stuff tied together but the
reason it's important to have an array
right now we've we've only got one
buffer or at least well we could make a
lot of them obviously and we will in a
minute actually we'll probably make more
for color as well why not but we'll have
what we have right now is we've got a
bunch of vertices and we kind of only
have one buffer yeah so why do we need
to enclose this in a vertex array that's
kind of a question that you guys might
have
well we need to transmit this data to
the graphics card right we need to use
we need to basically hand off all these
buffers onto our shader that's our only
goal that's why we're creating these
buffers so that our shaders get access
to this data from the CPU so to do that
right we need to use what are called
vertex attribute pointers now these
vertex attribute pointers are bound to a
certain vertex array okay so if we don't
actually create an array they'll just be
in kind of global space and it means
every single buffer will assume that the
exact same shaders are used in the sense
that when we specify and you and you'll
obviously see in a minute when we start
to use these vertex attribute pointers
but the a the idea is we want to only
modify vertex attribute pointers for our
array not everyone's array because when
we get on to more complex things and
when we want different kind of shaders
to draw different things a good example
would be drawing a 3d model versus text
on our screen we don't want to have the
same vertex attribute pointers okay we
don't need normals and lighting
positions for our text right so if we
don't use vertex arrays to enclose this
we're kind of forcing that upon
ourselves so where things are Ray's
gonna be much more complicated than all
the other stuff by the way so a vertex
array is so the other buffers were just
simple arrays like that simple arrays
and ironically vertex array is not
really an array well it's an array of
buffett's think of it that way right so
we'll start off with pragma once we will
grab our we'll grab this include as well
okay and then we'll have class vertex
array so a vertex array will also have
to have an array ID so Glu int M array
ID okay and then it should probably have
some kind of data structure which holds
all this buffers so I'm just gonna use a
simple vector for this so include vector
and then we'll just have a vector field
with buffers right down specifically the
pot pointers to buffers so we'll call
this m and buffers okay and make sure we
include our buffer okay so those are our
buffers and then when we create this
creating vertex array is probably gonna
be pretty simple we'll also make a
destructor so the idea is that when you
give this vertex array a buffer the
buffer now belongs to the vertex array
which means that it is now the bad X
rays job to maintain it so what I mean
by that is it does not get copied okay
there anything we could make it do that
but I think it'll probably make more
sense this way so when you create a
buffer it's memories now managed by the
array that you give it to okay which
also means that you can't give the same
buffer to numerous arrays you actually
have to create new buffers every time so
again that's kind of up to you how you
want to do it we'll do it like this for
now if we encounter any set any like I
don't know any problems with that
approach or we decide to change it
that'll be pretty easy to do so we'll
have to specify a buffer that we want to
add yeah add buffer I don't know why I
call the buffers but our buffer that we
want to add and then we actually need to
specify which vertex has to be pointer
index we want to use so Glu int index
all right
so when we start implementing this I
will explain so we'll have bind and
unbind and then that's pretty much all
we need to start implementing this stuff
so we'll include a vertex array dot H
and now namespaces I wish little studio
would stop trying to drop it onto new
your lines cuz it's getting annoying to
face this anyway vertex array that is
right so you can start it still does
need to do things by the way it does
need to generate how vertex arrays so we
want to generate a one array and M ray
IDs what we're gonna pass in there the
destructor we'll do that okay so the
destructor will go through all of our
entire vector essentially and delete
everything in that vector so it's really
as simple as for int I equals 0 is less
than am buffers dot size I plus plus
then we can just call delete M buffers I
okay it's that simple and that will just
delete all of our buffers from memory
okay and by buffers I mean literally
like these buffer objects okay so next
up let's implement the ad buffer which
is going to be the meaty kind of method
in this class so the buffer we want to
add of course and then the index that we
want to add it at so the index is but is
literally the shader index so what I
mean by this is that you see how in our
shaders we have this layout location
equals 0 yeah
for position and then if we added say
color we might make that location equal
to 1 well basically this is going to
correspond this index is gonna
correspond to this index okay so we need
to somehow get this buffer to be pointed
into this location so that's what this
is therefore and this is better so right
now that has buffer okay so first we
need to bind our bed x-ray which needs
to be ended by nine binds then we need
to bind whatever buffer we probably
don't actually
to find it Buffett away I'm gonna say we
probably don't I could be wrong though
I'm not wrong I'm not wrong okay I don't
think we need to bind the buffer we'll
see there we will enable a divert extra
attribute array okay and then this array
will be at the index okay so this
enables this attribute array and now we
want to actually point it we basically
want to point the buffer or we do have
to enable the buffer obviously otherwise
it doesn't know what buffer the point
where I am wrong so buffer binds buffer
unbind okay so basically we specify a
buffer by binding it right and it will
now take this buffer and bind it to this
shader index essentially right so to do
that we call vertex a three pointer okay
the first thing is the index so this
index this first parameter will
correspond to this okay to this
attribute index the second parameter is
the size so the size will basically just
so this isn't the size and bytes or
anything it's the size in terms of
components so that's where our buffer
dot gate component count comes in all
right the type so the type of data so
it's always going to be trail flirt
because that's what we specified in our
buffer over here right gel float or
rather where do we specify that in oh
well we didn't really specified in but
we gave it there is gel float right so
that's the data we gave it so we need to
read it now normalized there's always
entry false our dollars on wise so
stride and pointer can both be 0 for
this but if we were packing multiple if
this buffer had more than just one set
of say vertices so once said avec fours
it had like deck falls for like 5
different sprites we would have to
actually change the stride and the
offsets and whatnot to configure them to
do that so the stride will basically be
the size of each thing whereas the
offset would be
be current offset of like for this
specific pointer okay so yes anyway
that's it that's it
so we also probably want to don't forget
to and buffer into here if you don't
want to have any kind of memory
management and what I mean by that is
you don't actually want to have this
vertex array take control of the buffer
you can just remove this and that's
that's that that's done okay it's just
that it's a good idea to keep it alive
kind of in here because we don't want to
delete it we want to kind of once we're
done with our buffers it might be
tempted to just delete them outside of
this right what we do want what we kind
of want to do instead because we don't
need them once we've added them to the
array right but we don't want to delete
them either because what if we need to I
don't know rebind them or what it like
we need to keep the idea to keep the
actual but like Open GL buffer alive
which it will do by itself it's not
actually tied to the CPUs in memory
management but if we want to change that
buffer for example we can't if we've
lost it if we've deleted it so we want
to keep it so I just thought a suitable
place to keep it would be inside the
inside the destructor no inside the N
buffers factor okay cool anyway now
we've done that let's have binds which
we'll just call GL binds vertex array
with the array ID and then we'll have
unbind
all right cool so anyway that's pretty
much it
so we're now ready to actually test this
it's done to the point that we have a
vertex array we've got the ability to
create index buffers and vertex buffers
or just normal buffers really but we can
fill them with vertices we can pass them
into the vertex array and then we can
draw that okay so let's go ahead and try
that so right now we're drawing things
right now if we run out our game we're
just basically drawing we're drawing
things using just this simple gel draw
arrays right and we're drawing a bunch
of these vertices so and we're doing all
this OpenGL stuff in here right so let's
go ahead and include sauce / graphics /
buffers / buffer and index buffer and
vertex array okay and then all this
stuff I'm just going to go ahead and say
zero so basically I'm disabling all this
code from even being compiled because I
don't want that and I'll minimize this
so it's internet you know active
preprocessor block won't actually get
compiled I'll do the same here but with
an Al's probably in fact I'll do the
else with the other thing as well so um
yeah so I might as well just say else
okay and then we'll do our else stuff
here so this is going to be our system
this is the old system where we have to
do everything by ourselves this is the
new system using these objects that we
just created so let's go ahead and
create a vertex array so I'll just call
this VAR right vertex array object will
create a vertex buffer sorry it's just a
buffer
so prepare to buffer are called VBO
server takes a buffer object because
it'll be four vertices we'll go ahead
and okay so it wants we might as well
call around on the on the ape I guess so
it wants a bunch of floats so basically
it wants these right so let's copy these
vertices place them in here remember
we're using indices so we don't need to
duplicate it so if we look through this
you can see this is exactly the same as
is this and sorry as is this and that so
we don't need this and we don't need
that okay so now we have zero zero which
is the bottom then we're going
anti-clockwise here to two eight zero
right then we're going up to zero three
which is wrong because we willing to do
that and then we start good so what I
did I draw return you know that's just
kind of copy disorder so we had zero
being this way and then we went up so we
draw it we draw clockwise basically so
let's just change it to use clockwise
doesn't really matter once we do enable
calling that for OpenGL we do need to
remember to Center an actual we remember
to set it to clockwise otherwise it will
cold otherwise it'll seem this is a back
face anyway that is later cool so that
looks pretty good
those are our vertices now let's define
our indices which are unsigned shorts so
indices equals all this cool stuff
so in our indices again we'll just have
0 1 2 so we'll draw this one this one
this one so 1 2 3 and then we sorry so 0
1 2 0 1 2 and then 2 3 0 that looks ok
that sounds good
to 3zr ok done there we go so we've got
our index buffer and our vertex buffer
objects so in our vertex buffer will
specify these vertices the size so the
size that we specify here officer since
we are multiplying it by the size of gel
flow it really just needs to be the size
of this so it looks like we've got four
of them and they
three components each so I'll just go
four times three and then the component
count is three because they're kind of
BEC threes right okay cool we could
probably guess our buffers in the future
by the way to take in actual vector e so
that we can just specify four factories
and instead of having to do this this
way not that this is bad or anything but
we just could do that right and then
we'll finally we'll make a an index
buffered as well so index buffer Ivo
index Potter object will take an hour
indices and there's six of them so there
we go
cool done so now we need to add that vbo
into our a vo v AO so v bo at index zero
okay because we want it to be this
location equals zero
okay cool so back in Maine everything's
looking pretty good I think so okay so
let's just try drawing it now back in
here we'll go ahead and copy so instead
of jail draw arrays will be using
chilled draw elements okay we want to
draw them still as triangles okay the
next thing is the count so there's six
of them but we don't want to obviously
right at six we want to go our index
buffer so I vo dots get count obviously
we need to bind these things limit as
well the type will be GL unsigned short
and then the indices will be okay so we
can just say zero because we're binding
our indices right we don't actually need
to put them in as Donna here so let's
bind our vieo so VA o dot bind once
we've done that we want to find out Ibo
and at the end let's just unbind it to
be nice
there we go we could just leave a bound
officer but there we go so we bind our
vertex array object and our index buffer
object and all this stuff and simply
like it honestly should basically work
the exact same way so if we launch this
now hopefully we get the exact same
result
okay there we go so but now is using our
new system okay so pretty cool now yeah
this should work for multiples multiple
things as well so we'll add color and
stuff in a minute but if I for example
into this vertex array let's just say I
like I don't know
mmm what's a good test to do all right
we could draw two of these by just
simply having true draw elements but
then we could set say the model matrix
which is over here what's that one of
them to this one and one of them to this
one so four three and maybe zero zero so
we're drawing the same thing twice now
there it is one ones there ones there
pretty cool stuff okay anyway let's go
ahead and try to give these things
different colors by using a color buffer
so if we make a GL float filled with
colors so I'll call this colors so we'll
say maybe maybe okay well I don't know
let's just go ahead and say we'll make
the first one pink alpha as well so we
need to do this per vertex by the way
which is like about four times so this
will be colors a and colors B and the
second one will just make like that old
clear color that we had which was like
zero point 2f 0.3 f 0.8
all right cool so now we've got two
different colors let's go ahead and
create a so we've got our Bao let's go
let's just say like sprite one sprite -
okay and then we'll have this buffer so
we can't unfortunately just hit up the
arrow to add buffer like we can't just
go sprite wonder that buffer and then
sprite one dot sprite or a buffer
because remember this it's it's the same
buffer and it will explode because when
we basically when we close this
application of VO we'll get destructed
this sprite one and whatever we'll get
distracted I'll try to delete the same
memory twice because it is the same
memory so what we need to do is that is
probably recreate it again so I'll just
go ahead and do this and step in really
need this here okay the Ibo we can keep
the same right we don't need to have two
different ideas what do you need to have
two different ones of this and then we
can have another buffer okay which is
going to be our color buffer so this all
taking our colors a okay what is it it's
four times four okay
what's three again the number of
components right four and then over here
we'll have it at index one so that's our
setting up sprite one that's us setting
up sprite
two colors B otherwise it's exactly the
same right
so now over here we're still drawing it
twice and whatnot let's um go ahead and
well it'll be bit different and drawing
it twice obviously because we want to
change this stuff but sprite one so
we're doing all this cool stuff then
we're drawing it and then we'll do the
same thing over here but
so we're binding sprite - now we need to
rebind the Ibo because remember the IBO
gets bound into the video so that's kind
of important if you're you can't
unfortunately can't just bind it once
for both of these videos because it
needs to get bound when the video when
the appropriate video is actually bound
and by vieo i mean that dex array object
okay anyway we've got this stuff here
everything is good so really all we need
to do now is actually get the trailer to
accept these colors that we're giving it
they were forcing upon us so in here I'm
going to duplicate this set it to one
right and I'm setting it to one because
I set this thing here to one okay for
our colors so this one will pull those
colors it'll still be back for right I
guess let's call one color because it is
let's go ahead and quickly create some
kind of struct thing for this so we'll
go ahead and say out data okay and then
we'll call it something along the lines
of BS out but there decorate it out and
then I'll just move this stuff into it
just so that we can have duplicate names
kind of you'll see so we don't need this
anymore
so back for Pizitz oh this will be just
I'll just call this position and then
we'll have back for color okay and over
here I'll set the vs out dot position
equal to bat and then ya also said vs
out dot color able to do color okay
which is out here so we need a another
one of these data is the name that it
uses to communicate so in here we need
an in data okay everything else is the
same we'll call this F s in fragment
shader in so over here we'll just set so
colors right now is being set to our
uniform color but instead let's go ahead
and set color so I'll comment that out
and I'll just set color which is our out
color equal to FS in color pretty cool
also I think that this might have been
something that I did an on stream but
off video so in the previous episode
that was something
out lighting not being scented because
we weren't translating it by the model
so I think we had to like that before
I just added the model matrix into here
so that the light position would be
black position that gets calculated
based on this position would actually be
relative to these like the actual like
relative to the relative to the actual
like screen instead of to the actual
primitive that we were drawing okay so
that might be new but it's here okay
cool
so that looks pretty good to me would it
would showing the color yeah
everything's good so make sure this
position though is FS in dot positioned
XY okay cool anyway that should compile
let's run this okay cool
so there we go pink and that blue color
that I was talking about pretty cool so
out here though I think we're still
setting that uniform color aren't we
well using it but we're still setting it
yeah so that's all right let's quickly
change this to be x intensity so if we
go back to that old color we should see
yeah that and then if we go to this new
color which is now say that pair one of
them's being pink and stuff yeah pretty
cool stuff all right cool so there we go
any questions leave them in the comments
below everything else looks good and
there wasn't anything else I wanna cover
yes one more thing I actually want to
talk about is if we were to get an error
for example what would happen so GL on
sine sure is what we're using right now
what if we accidentally use GL short or
something what happens does everything
just work well no it doesn't draw at all
and there aren't really any visible
problems as in nothing is complaining to
us being like you used the wrong enum
okay so we want to kind of mistakes like
this can unfortunately take a while to
debug
so to aid that there should be a way for
us to check for errors well luckily
OpenGL does give us a way to check for
errors so this is an example of an error
because indices have to be unsigned so
if we use something that is signed
OpenGL recognizes that as an error even
though in this case technically the data
would still work but OpenGL refuses to
render it because of this error so we
need a way to detect these errors
so if we're going to our window class
real quick what we can do in every time
we update for example which is over here
a good weight would like a like the best
way to do this would probably be after
every single opengl like function we
call we want to actually check for
errors but that's going to be we might
set that up eventually when we actually
encounter these errors but for now we
can literally do something on the lines
of GL error or something like sorry GL
UNAM so GL enum equals and we'll call it
error write equals GL guess error okay
so they'll get an error code for us and
then we can say that if error doesn't
equal GL no error it means there is an
error so what we should do is basically
print out that error so we can just go
open GL error and then that error code
followed by an end line okay and with
this system if we do do something like
GL shorter set of unsigned short and we
call it you'll see that we should
actually get error 1280 which is invalid
enum which means we've basically done
something like this we've used the we've
used the wrong in it where V is the
wrong enum here for example so if we
change this back to unsigned short we
should have any errors all right and as
you can see nothing okay so now that's
just something I wanted to put in for T
bugging in the future because it is kind
of important but other than that there
we go we've got two different ways to
draw things now this one is
significantly better because we use our
own kind of API for that and it simply
wraps around opengl stuff and does a lot
of the kind of work behind the scenes
and it seems to work with multiple
buffers as well which is nice so any
questions leave them below next episode
were probably going to move on to
actually implementing these renderers so
right now we've got all this stuff
implemented next time we're going to
move on to creating renderable 3ds and
probably getting a renderer to handle
this rather than all of us doing it
the main function so yeah if you guys
enjoyed this video please hit the like
button and I will see you next time
goodbye